Ukraine has urged its citizens in Russia
to leave immediately it says Russian
aggression is increasing and so too the
threat of invasion after moscow's
recognition of two Breakaway regions as
independent states
in other developments Ukraine is
preparing a month-long state of
emergency according to its top security
official the Ukrainian Parliament has
approved a draft law allowing all
ukrainians to carry firearms and act in
self-defense and Kiev is calling up some
reservists for military duty
and general Rio Terrace joins us from
Estonia he was a commander in the
Estonian Defense Forces now a member of
the European Parliament do you expect
the Russian president to launch a
full-scale invasion of Ukraine
I think it is still very much possible
if we listen to his speech a day before
yesterday then it was the war
declaration even though on the end it
that didn't come to it but talking about
how Ukraine is not the state uh I think
he um showed that the the Strategic aim
is to change the government in Kiev and
by just operating in Donetsk and donbas
he will not reach the aim of changing
the government to a government which is
more suitable for Putin or recognizing
putting as is as the superior
now the Ukrainian military has issued in
order to call up reservists from a
military standpoint
can Ukraine withstand a Russian
offensive
yeah anyway Russia has never in the in
the last decades or even since second
world war faced uh and um an army big
that big as the Ukrainian uh and uh and
little Finland 1939 has showed that you
can fight with the with the big enemies
so I think Ukrainian Army uh and
Ukrainian state is very much ready to
fight for the for the values democratic
values and and fight for their
independence I have seen that in the
eyes of the soldiers in in Ukrainian
demarcation line a couple of days ago
they want they are ready to fight for
their country do you see a military
option or is diplomacy the only way out
of this
well I don't think Putin understands
diplomacy because every attempt to reach
the hand towards him he has not taken
the peaceful hand so I don't think
putting once a diplomatic solution uh
if of course if he would do that then it
is very positive but then he has to
withdraw from the Donetsk and lugansk
where his troops are right now and give
back here
sorry
you tweeted yesterday that bold steps
are needed to put delusional Putin in
his place what are those steps
yeah for uh from uh from uh saying uh
NATO's perspective I would say nato has
been showing it's very very
um a big Unity they're very focused NATO
has never been stronger uh as as it is
right now and that is caused by putting
its Behavior Uh European Union has put
on sanctions and or is just about to put
sanctions on on Russian Russians uh
again very much unified even though uh
people thought that some countries will
not support these sanctions they are so
very strong sanctions and even Germany
has uh at least postponed for the
current moment the the north swing too
so these are the these are the steps but
I am convinced that Ukraine needs
financial and Military uh help military
by military health I mean
ammunition and stocks to support them
and on that front U.S President Biden
announced yesterday he would be sending
more troops to the Baltic States
including Estonia where you are to
bolster NATO's Eastern flank how's that
going to help
well NATO is determined to defend the
NATO's territories Estonian Latvian
Lithuanian armed forces are ready to
defend the territories and the NATO's
eastern border and our allies not only
us but but France
Germany Canada
Denmark and others are sending
additional troops to the region
understanding that this is a fight for
for democratic values and Poland is
ready so to show strengths is the only
way of Putin understands the only
language put in understand Rio Terrace
former commander of the Estonian Defense
Forces thank you very much for being on
the show today
thank you very much relations between
Ukraine and Russia are at their lowest
point in years Kiev has recalled its
ambassador from Moscow and is
considering ending all diplomatic ties
it wasn't all that long ago the Ukraine
had a pro-russian president
Putin had a
head of Heaven for Russia president was
very important for Russia it meant that
a lot of reforms would be stalled it
meant that any Union with the West would
not be possible and in 2013 when
Yanukovych refused to sign an
association agreement for closer ties to
the EU
the people rebelled
scores died hundreds were injured in the
maidon revolution
Yanukovych was ousted and a new pro-eu
government formed
the Kremlin answered back
with tanks an annexed Ukraine's Crimean
peninsula
Moscow also threw its support behind
separatists in the pro-russia donbass
region
war broke out as the two Eastern
provinces Donetsk and Nuance declared
independence
European leaders brought the two sides
together for the mince Peace Accords but
the war ground to a stalemate
a development far from the battlefield
also spiked tensions
in June 2015 Russia announced the
Nordstrom 2 gas pipeline its route under
the Baltic Sea would bypass Ukraine
meaning Kiev would lose billions in
transit fees
another turning point in 2019 with
Vladimir zielinski as Ukraine's
president
he vowed to restore the donbass region
and renewed calls for NATO membership
many leaders hint slightly that Ukraine
shouldn't take the risk of talking
constantly about membership of the
alliance because this risk is connected
to Russia's reaction but that was a red
line for Moscow
no one thought that if Ukraine creates
such threats for Russia it creates
similar threats for herself
it was one of Putin's justifications for
the Russian troop buildup around
Ukraine's borders
but unlike eight years ago Ukraine is a
battle-hardened nation that's vowed to
resist
well Germany's foreign minister Angelina
bebok has been addressing the Russian
moves against Ukraine is some of what
she had to say
Russian president is trying to turn back
the wheel of history in eastern Ukraine
at the expense of his neighbors with
power with military force with absolute
contempt for everything that defines the
legal and peaceful order in Europe
and not least with indifference towards
the fate of the people affected on both
sides
mention of Biden zeiten
Germany's top Diplomat and now our chief
political correspondent Melinda crane
what do you make of what the foreign
minister said well she was meeting with
her French colleague foreign minister Le
Trion and both of them were at Great
pains to put on a very Resolute display
of unity and after that statement she
went on to essentially lay out the goals
of the sanctions that were imposed by
the EU yesterday and which include the
momentous decision by Germany to defer
certification of the nordstream II gas
pipeline from Russia which will impose
pain in Russia but also some real
economic hardship for Germany as well so
she said the goal is not simply to deter
Russia from further escalation yes
that's important but beyond that it is
to reinforce important Norms of
international law like territorial
integrity and she went on to say and I
quote we are ready to pay a high price
for a free and Sovereign Ukraine and you
know sometimes the norm of territorial
Integrity can sound like an abstraction
but let's listen to Chancellor Olaf
Schultz of Germany explain what would
happen in Europe if we simply sweep
aside norms and rules that have been
placed since the Second World War
if you look back far enough in history
you will find many borders that were
different back then if we reopen
discussion on all of them we will face
very troubled times that is why we must
urgently return to this principle State
sovereignty is respected borders are not
violated what Putin and his Parliament
have decided is a breach of
international law that we cannot and
will not accept
so what role is chancellor shelter's
government playing in addressing the
crisis well and not only foreign
minister bar Buck but also her French uh
colleague both said very clearly that
these sanctions are simply a first stage
both are aware that there could be
further escalation measures by Germany
by Russia and that they would by no
means necessarily only be in the form of
a full invasion but could take other
forms as well for example a Cyber attack
and yet the foreign minister the German
foreign minister and Chancellor
Schultz's government as a whole has been
very clear that diplomatic Outreach
remains a necessity and she said the
fact is that we have said to Russia come
back to the table we do not accept that
they have simply thrown out the process
of talks called the Norman deform format
that they have ripped to shreds the
Minsk agreement that was supposed to try
to find a solution to stabilize eastern
Ukraine and nonetheless we say we are
ready to talk and then she said in
English we said to Russia you need to
come back to the table
would it have made any difference if
she'd said it in Russian
Belinda crane thank you very much for
the analysis